Business, business, business. Numbers. Is this working? Yes. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, Episode 99, recorded on September 25th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we finish part three of our three-part interview with Sean Baxter and changed topics to Moby Dick and our favorite movies. All right, so I think we got to talk about the last thing that we promised the users we would talk about. Connor, have you read Moby Dick? I actually haven't. I've read In the Heart of the Sea, which is the book that Moby Dick was based on. Sean, is that correct? Oh, no, I think you're talking about The Sinking of the Essex. There is a Nathaniel Philbrick book, I think, called The Heart of the Sea.
商业、商业、商业。数字。这个能用吗？可以。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 99 期，录制于 2022 年 9 月 25 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天和我一起主持的搭档是布莱斯（Bryce）。我们完成了与肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）的三期访谈的第三部分，并将话题转向了《白鲸记》和我们最喜欢的电影。好的，我想我们得聊聊我们之前答应听众要聊的最后那件事了。康纳，你读过《白鲸记》吗？我其实没读过。我读过《海洋深处》，那是《白鲸记》取材的那本书。肖恩，是这样吗？哦，不，我想你说的应该是《埃塞克斯号的沉没》。纳撒尼尔·菲尔布里克（Nathaniel Philbrick）好像写过一本书叫《海洋深处》。
Right. That's a recent book, but it's talking about an actual ship that was hit by a whale and sunk in the uh 1830s and that kind of was like part of the legend um oh so it was a recent book that actually tells the story that the story that moby dick was sort of based on, correct? Well. Here we go. I don't know how much time we have. We have.
对。那是本新书，但它讲的是一艘真实的船，在 1830 年代被一头鲸鱼撞击并沉没的故事，这在某种程度上成了传说的一部分。哦，所以这是一本新书，讲述了《白鲸记》所取材的那个故事，对吗？好吧。我们开始吧。我不知道我们还有多少时间。我们还有。
Look, Sean, we did an episode where I talked about my criterion for restaurant bathrooms and how much I love. No, no, that did not air. You what? Connor, you got to put that. You have to air that. All right. So, okay. All right.
听着，肖恩，我们曾录过一期节目，我谈到了我对餐馆卫生间的标准以及我有多么热爱……不，不，那一期没播。你说什么？康纳，你得把那个播出来。你得把它播出来。好吧。所以，好吧。好吧。
Moby Dick. Okay. So to get this out of the way, Moby Dick is a really funny book. It's fun to read. The metaphors are thick and they're outrageous. Ishmael is your guide and he is, he's like a very modern mind. He's the kind of guy who now would go to wikipedia all the time and tell you of all those like crazy discoveries going down the rabbit hole
《白鲸记》。好吧，为了长话短说，《白鲸记》是一本非常有趣的书。读起来很有意思。其中的隐喻铺天盖地，而且异想天开。以实玛利（Ishmael）是你的向导，他非常有现代思维。他就像那种现在会频繁刷维基百科，然后向你讲述各种疯狂发现、越陷越深的人。
so it's like it's a really gregarious book but for me it has continuing resonance because it is our national myth and do you know about like national myths? You know, like there was the... Like the Loch Ness Monster? No, like the Bronze Age collapse. So between 1200 BC and 800 BC, Bronze Age civilization around the Greek islands collapsed. The population fell. They lost technology.
所以这是一本非常具有社交属性的书，但对我来说，它有着持续的共鸣，因为它是我们的民族神话。你知道什么是民族神话吗？你知道的，就像有……就像尼斯湖水怪？不，就像青铜时代崩溃。所以在公元前 1200 年到公元前 800 年之间，希腊群岛周边的青铜时代文明崩溃了。人口减少了。他们失去了技术。
There's like no writing. There's no history from that period. And so in 800 BC, when Homer and Herodototus are walking around they have this sophisticated greek language they have the alphabet for the first time they record their thoughts and they look around and we have all these like legends but we don't like know where we came from so they you know he writes like the iliad which is the story of the greek war against Trojans, which is where Constantinople is now, and how the Greek modern people came to be. After this Bronze Age collapse, that became the national myth.
那个时期几乎没有文字。没有那个时期的历史。所以在公元前 800 年，当荷马和希罗多德四处游历时，他们拥有了复杂的希腊语，第一次有了字母表，他们记录自己的思想，环顾四周，我们有所有这些传说，但我们不知道我们从哪里来，所以你知道的，他写了《伊利亚特》，那是关于希腊人攻打特洛伊（也就是现在的君士坦丁堡）的故事，以及现代希腊人是如何诞生的。在这次青铜时代崩溃之后，这就成了民族神话。
Everyone would plug in to that, and they'd write drama, and they'd write songs, and they'd do sculptures and paintings and whatnot from these national myths and in virgil who was the roman uh poet during the time of like augustus caesar in the first century bc he did the aeneid which is how uh descendants from troy fleeing the sack of troy found their way through egypt and came up to uh rome and settled rome and this was kind of glory for the country. It showed like we're like not just the powerhouse of the world, but we have this amazing national inheritance from the Greeks. And after the thousand-year dark age in England,
每个人都会融入其中，他们会创作戏剧、写歌、制作雕塑和绘画等等，素材都取自这些民族神话。而维吉尔（Virgil），也就是公元前一世纪奥古斯都·凯撒时期的罗马诗人，创作了《埃涅阿斯纪》，讲述了特洛伊沦陷时逃离的特洛伊后裔如何经由埃及来到罗马并定居罗马，这对国家来说是一种荣耀。这表明我们不仅是世界上的超级大国，而且我们从希腊人那里继承了惊人的民族遗产。在经历了英国长达千年的黑暗时代之后，
you have the Arthurian legends in the Middle Ages that were kind of discovered and formed into coherent prose by Mallory and like a bunch of itinerant traveling poets. They created the Arthurian legends. And this is basically Christianized versions of the Greek stories. And in 1667, you have the publication of Paradise Lost, John Milton. He was a religious extremist during the wars of religion, like the Thirty Years' War destroyed Europe, and then the English Civil War in 1648 that killed the king, and then Cromwell was beheaded, and bloodshed everywhere. and kind of the fundamentalist Puritans. And Milton tries to create a national myth for Protestantism. He creates Paradise Lost, which is telling the story in the Bible, but in the language and poetry of Homer. And the idea is to give your own culture or religious movement more intellectual credibility
你在中世纪有了亚瑟王传说，它们被马洛里（Malory）和一群四处游历的诗人们发现并整理成了连贯的散文。他们创造了亚瑟王传说。这基本上是希腊故事的基督教化版本。到了 1667 年，约翰·弥尔顿（John Milton）出版了《失乐园》。他是宗教战争时期的宗教极端分子，比如三十年战争摧毁了欧洲，然后是 1648 年杀死国王的英国内战，接着克伦威尔被斩首，到处都是流血事件。还有那些原教旨主义清教徒。弥尔顿试图为新教创造一个民族神话。他创作了《失乐园》，讲述了圣经中的故事，但使用的是荷马的语言和诗歌。其核心思想是赋予你自己的文化或宗教运动更多的知识信誉，
by linking it with this tradition of the national myth. And I think what's incredible about Moby Dick is that it was published in 1851 by a 31-year-old Melville, I think he was, super young, to create this amazing work. But he nails the idea of the national myth because he sees America as the sole superpower of the world in 1850. And he sees it because the American whaler is all over the entire globe. And we're the only whaling power that butchers the sperm whale, which is the tooth whale, like the man-eater, and breaks it down entirely in the boat to create a single, self-sufficient oil industry at sea.
通过将其与民族神话的传统联系起来。我认为《白鲸记》不可思议的地方在于，它是由 31 岁的梅尔维尔于 1851 年出版的，当时他非常年轻，却创作出了这部惊世之作。但他精准地抓住了民族神话的精髓，因为他在 1850 年将美国视为世界上唯一的超级大国。他之所以能看到这一点，是因为美国的捕鲸船遍布全球各地。我们是唯一一个屠宰抹香鲸（也就是齿鲸、食人鲸）的捕鲸强国，并在船上将其完全分解，在海上建立起一个单一的、自给自足的石油工业。
And he sees this as the Navy for the United States. And for him, the idea of jousting the sperm whale, not just like staying off the coast of greenland and hunting right whales which are docile idiots but going after the the the sperm whale in the pacific and chasing it and jousting it lance to jaw is like the most ambitious arrogant thing you can do because it's the biggest animal that's ever been on the planet, and we are fighting it. And I think if, you know, this is 1850 before the Civil War when America was still, like, not really on the world stage.
他认为这就是美利坚的海军。对他来说，与抹香鲸搏斗的理念——不仅仅是停留在格陵兰岛海岸去猎捕温顺的露脊鲸，而是去太平洋追逐抹香鲸，用鱼叉刺向它们的下颚——这是你能做出的最雄心勃勃、最狂妄自大的事情，因为它是地球历史上出现过的最大的动物，而我们正在与它战斗。我认为，如果，你知道的，这是 1850 年内战前夕，当时美国还算不上真正登上世界舞台。
But if he was writing in the, like, 1900, he would be writing about skyscrapers. Or in the 40s, he'd be writing about the bomb. Or in the 60s, he'd be writing about the moonshot. What happened to the moonshot? In 1969, like, it's the greatest human achievement of all time to walk on the moon and then we go back and we're hitting golf balls like it's such contemptuous it's it's a an act that's so contemptuous of the challenge that we we trivialize it by by hitting golf balls on the moon on the next couple go-arounds and i think that's like the true arrogance and ambition of America.
但如果他是生活在 1900 年代左右，他就会写摩天大楼。如果在 40 年代，他会写原子弹。如果在 60 年代，他会写登月。登月怎么了？在 1969 年，登上月球是人类有史以来最伟大的成就，然后我们回去了，还在上面打高尔夫球。这简直是对挑战的一种极度蔑视，我们通过在接下来的几次登月中在月球上打高尔夫球，将这种挑战轻浮化了。我认为这才是美国真正的傲慢与雄心。
And that is captured by Melville in Ahab representing America, which is America is just ambition on a national level, right? We are not about tradition. We are about doing the impossible. Even if it's foolish, it doesn't matter. He just loves the impossible. So yeah, Moby Dick is basically about Ahab, even if it's foolish it doesn't matter it's it just he just loves the impossible so um yeah Moby Dick is basically about Ahab who goes on an adventure with this Parsi the Parsi is a Zoroastrian
梅尔维尔通过代表美国的亚比顿（Ahab）捕捉到了这一点，美国在国家层面上就是野心勃勃，对吧？我们不拘泥于传统。我们致力于完成不可能之事。即使它是愚蠢的，也无所谓。他就是热爱不可能之事。所以，是的，《白鲸记》基本上是关于亚比顿的，即使它是愚蠢的，也无所谓，他只是热爱不可能之事。所以，是的，《白鲸记》基本上是关于亚比顿的，他带着一个帕西人去冒险，这个帕西人是一个祆教徒，
um which is a kind of a pre-Christian religion in Persia and they were run out of Iran during the Islamic um expansion like the 7th and 8th century, and they went to India. They're kind of like fire worshipers in these fire temples. And the idea of the sun is like really pertinent. And I think the Romantic movement started kind of like during the French Revolution and kind of went to the end of the 19th century, of which Melville is like a high Romantic artist. They're really interested in comparative religion and he sees Zoroastrianism as an alternate alternative to Christianity create religious conflict um so that Ahab who is a Quaker and he speaks with this King James Version Bible language and all his friends are Quakers and the three mates on the ship
也就是波斯的一种前基督教宗教。在伊斯兰教在 7 到 8 世纪扩张期间，他们被赶出了伊朗，逃到了印度。他们有点像这些火神庙里的拜火教徒。太阳的概念真的非常贴切。我认为浪漫主义运动大约始于法国大革命期间，一直持续到 19世纪末，梅尔维尔就是一位高度浪漫主义的艺术家。他们对比较宗教学非常感兴趣，他将祆教视为基督教的替代方案，从而制造宗教冲突。因此，亚比顿是一个贵格会教徒，他操着《詹姆斯王钦定版圣经》的语言说话，他的所有朋友都是贵格会教徒，船上的三位大副
are Quakers and the Bildad and Peleg, the owners of the ship who outfitted are Quakers. Like Ahab was a Quaker but now he's got these other ideas about the Godhead and the Infinite and he's led to believe that Moby Dick, the whale, is Job's Leviathan, is the sea beast that God sent to Earth to torment mankind and kind of like show us our place. So Ahab is given this idea by Fadala, the Zoroastrian, that by striking through the whale, he can go to the other side and strike at God himself. So I think this is about the ambition of America, where Melville's own career started about, well, we're going to only fight the sperm whale because to fight any other kind of whale is beneath us. It's not macho. But how do you get more macho than fighting the largest animal that ever lived?
都是贵格会教徒，出资装备这艘船船主比尔达（Bildad）和佩莱格（Peleg）也是贵格会教徒。亚比顿以前是个贵格会教徒，但现在他对神性和无限有了其他看法，他开始相信白鲸就是约伯记中的利维坦，是上帝派到人间来折磨人类并显示我们地位的海怪。因此，祆教徒法达拉（Fadala）给了亚比顿这样一个想法：通过刺穿这头鲸鱼，他可以穿到另一端去攻击上帝本身。所以我觉得这关乎美国的野心，梅尔维尔自己的职业生涯也是从这里开始的：好吧，我们只跟抹香鲸搏斗，因为去跟其他任何种类的鲸鱼搏斗都有失我们的身份。那不够有男子气概。但还有什么比跟有史以来最大的动物搏斗更有男子气概的呢？
Make that largest animal that ever lived make that largest animal that ever lived um the the agent of god and so by striking through that you strike at god himself and this this goes into this romantic recontextualization of paradise lost and how it connects with national myths that kind of connected all of like western civilization together it's just it's a whole bunch of metaphysics that is that is advanced by ahab's ambition and at the same time you have this kind of encyclopedic curiosity in the in the in the voice of ishmael which is like melville's alter ego that's understandable to us so we have this running commentary by Ishmael, and then we have these kind of dark, elusive motivations of Ahab and his quest to hunt and destroy this, not quite animal, but really the supernatural being.
把那头有史以来最大的动物……把那头有史以来最大的动物变成上帝的代理人，通过刺穿它来攻击上帝本身。这就融入了对《失乐园》的浪漫主义重新语境化，以及它如何与将整个西方文明联系在一起的民族神话相连接。这只是一堆由亚比顿的雄心所推动的形而上学理论，与此同时，在以实玛利（也就是梅尔维尔的分身）的声音中，你又拥有这种百科全书般的好奇心，这是我们所能理解的。因此，我们有以实玛利的实时评论，然后又有亚比顿那种黑暗、捉摸不透的动机，以及他追捕并摧毁这头并非普通动物、而实则是超自然存在的猎物的执着。
And I think the ability to have a really daring metaphysical novel that's also like descriptive of America's ambition to come, which is, you know, dominance on the sea, dominance in the air, dominance in space. And to get all this in 1850 is like just an amazing thing. There's a lot going on. But I don't know. I love hearing you talk about Moby Dick.
我认为，能够写出一部既非常大胆又具有形而上学色彩，同时又能描绘美国未来野心的小说——你知道的，也就是对海洋的统治、对天空的统治、对太空的统治。在 1850 年就能写出这一切，简直是一件了不起的事情。里面包含的内容非常多。但我不知道。我就是喜欢听你谈论《白鲸记》。
Connor's going to have to go read Moby Dick now. I will. You've inspired me. That was masterful. Early on, there's a whole chapter on chowder. Like fish chowder or clam chowder. He spends pages and pages
康纳现在不得不去读《白鲸记》了。我会的。你激励了我。那真是大师级的讲解。在书的开头，有一整章都在讲周 chowder（蛤蜊浓汤）。比如鱼类杂烩汤或蛤蜊浓汤。他花了整整好几页
on silly stuff but at the same time you've got this this magma that's like animating some of the characters and it's the high and low just like shakespeare it's like high and low everywhere and he works on so many uh registers of communication just uh and he's a new york And he's a New Yorker. He's like, you can walk up Broadway and you can see all the places he lives. He's buried in the Bronx. You can go visit his grave. He's buried in the Bronx? Yeah, take the 6 train all the way up to the Vaughan Cemetery.
来写这些看似无聊的东西，但与此同时，你又会发现这种如同岩浆般充满活力的东西在某些角色身上流淌。这融合了阳春白雪和下里巴人，就像莎士比亚的作品一样，处处皆是阳春白雪与下里巴人。他运用了如此多的交流语域，而且他是个纽约人。而且他是个纽约人。就像，你可以沿着百老汇大街走，看到他住过的所有地方。他安葬在布朗克斯区。你可以去参观他的墓。他安葬在布朗克斯区？对，坐 6 号线一直坐到沃恩公墓（Woodlawn Cemetery）。
And you can go see his headstone there, right? You see, I'm at the confluence of New York. I can go anywhere. I can get to anything. I'm right off the 6. Yeah, there you go. Bryce is going to go there tomorrow. He's going to visit Melville.
你就能去那里看他的墓碑，对吧？你看，我正处于纽约的交汇点。我可以去任何地方。我可以到达任何地方。我就在 6 号线旁边。对，就是这样。布莱斯明天就要去那儿了。他要去拜访梅尔维尔。
Wow. Yeah, no, no. Tomorrow I've got to do high holidays, do stuff with my grandparents. All right, all right. When did you first read Moby Dick? Probably when I was like 22. I think I was just out of college.
哇。是的，不，不。明天我得过犹太教的高年节日（High Holidays），跟我祖父母一起过节。好吧，好吧。你是什么时候第一次读《白鲸记》的？大概在我 22 岁的时候吧。我想我刚大学毕业不久。
I had read a lot of, um, here's the thing. I was, like, a physics major, typical, like, sci-fi kind of nerd in high school. And then I thought, well, all I'm doing is, like, C++ programming and, like, physics homework. How do I communicate in the humanities? So I had this idea I could get, like, a general education. So I just started reading, like, really deeply kind of the canon. So I read, you know, I read, like, Iliad and the Odyssey. at like a general education so i just started reading like really deeply kind of the canon so i read you know i've read like iliad and the odyssey and i read like all every dickens novel
我读过很多，嗯，事情是这样的。我当时是个物理专业的学生，在高中时是个典型的科幻小说书呆子。然后我想，好吧，我整天做的事就是 C++ 编程和物理作业。我该如何在人文领域进行交流呢？所以我萌生了一个想法，我可以接受类似于通识教育的熏陶。于是我开始阅读，非常深入地阅读经典。所以我读了，你知道的，我读了《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》等通识教育读物，所以我就开始非常深入地阅读经典，比如我读了《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》，还读了狄更斯的所有小说。
um i read a whole bunch of i read like the three tolstoy novels and i read a bunch of cuba novels i just wanted to get like generally educated so at that point you know i was like 22 and i read moby dick i cried through it in a couple days and said, wow, this is truly next level stuff because not only is he working like the top of his game with respect to the other novelists of that mid-19th century, of which there's like, that modern novel was kind of created at that point by Flaubert and other social novelists, Balzac. He's not only doing that, but somehow he's able to tap in to Milton and Shakespeare
我读了大量的小说，比如我读了托尔斯泰的三部小说，还读了一堆库珀（Cooper）的小说。我只是想让自己获得通识教育。所以在那个时候，你知道的，我大概 22 岁，我读了《白鲸记》，我在几天内含着泪读完了它，然后说，哇，这真的是高阶内容，因为他不仅在 19 世纪中叶的其他小说家中达到了巅峰水平——当时的现代小说在某种程度上正是由福楼拜和其他社会小说家、巴尔扎克所开创的——他不仅做到了这一点，而且不知何故，他还能够汲取弥尔顿和莎士比亚的精髓，
and Aristotle and Aeschylus and unite the ideas of people over 2,000, 3,000 years of history in a way that makes it more or less intelligible today. What, like, his ambition in writing that novel
以及亚里士多德和埃斯库罗斯的思想，将两三千年历史中人们的思想融为一体，使其在今天或多或少依然能够被理解。什么，就像他在写作那部小说时的雄心，
is like the ambition of ahab hunting for god and why does ahab do it just because like it's something that he's doing it for the sake of ambition and doing something for the sake of ambition is at the heart of melville it's at the heart of ahab and it's a part of america and that i think is like amazing observation in 1850 this is a master class on, yeah, this, this, here, here's a very odd follow-up question. Cause I'm getting the sense that like, you're like,
就像亚比顿为了寻找上帝而进行的那种野心，而亚比顿为什么要这么做？只是因为这正是他正在做的事，他是为了野心而做这件事，而为了野心而做事的精神正是梅尔维尔的核心所在，是亚比顿的核心所在，也是美国的一部分，我认为这是 1850 年一个极其了不起的观察。这是一堂大师级的课，关于，是的，这个，这个，这里有一个非常奇怪的后续问题。因为我有一种感觉，你就像，
you're like a savant at like certain, you know, you're, Oh, I got to go get cultured. So I'm going to read every single, you know, X book. What's like a top five interesting facts about Sean, you know, already we know that you've so you can't include i've written you know single-handedly a c++ compiler and uh i could read a i could write a dissertation on uh moby dick uh what's what's your top five uh interesting facts about sean that uh are probably uh you know i i won't be surprised to hear based on now these last two things but just it's going to be like interesting,
你就像在某些领域是个学者，你知道的，你就像，“哦，我得去培养一下自己的文化素养，所以我要读完每一本 X 书。”关于肖恩的趣事，排名前五的是什么？你知道的，我们已经知道了，所以你不能包括“我独自一人编写了一个 C++ 编译器”以及“我可以写一篇关于《白鲸记》的论文”。关于肖恩，排名前五的趣事是什么，听了这两点之后我大概也不会感到惊讶，但这肯定会是一些很有趣的，
interesting facts. I probably shouldn't make a big deal about it, but I'm like very friendly with bartenders, I feel. Oh my God. Watching Sean romance a bartender, it's like, it's like X-rated, which. No, it's not. I'm very respectful of everyone.
有趣的事实。我可能不应该大惊小怪，但我觉得我和调酒师的关系都非常好。天哪。看着肖恩和调酒师调情，感觉就像是……像 R 级片一样，真是……不，不是的。我对所有人都非常尊重。
But just like. I just want to know about the liqueurs and Amari. We were at this nice restaurant in Aspen, and it was like a group of eight of us. And Sean's like, I'm going to make friends with the bartender. I'm like, by the end of the night, they're going to be sending me free drinks. No, no, no. Anyways, it's nice when you can nerd out. How extensive is your home bar? I haven't been replenishing it.
只是……我只是想了解烈酒和阿马罗苦露酒（Amari）。我们在阿斯本的一家不错的餐厅，当时我们大概有八个人。肖恩说：“我要去和调酒师交朋友。”我说：“到今晚结束时，他们会开始免费请我们喝酒的。”不，不，不。不管怎样，当你能沉浸在自己热衷的事物中时，感觉真的很棒。你家里的酒吧藏酒有多丰富？我最近没有去补充库存。
So, you know, I just, I'm just more curious about, like, I mean, it's interesting that there's, like, a drinking culture for every culture. And, like, it's such a specialized, localized thing that somehow made it through. Like you can go to places in New York where they have like two, 300 of Marlowe's on the, on the shelf. Things you've never seen that are produced in like really small numbers, even things like craft beer that, that I think Americans like really do well.
所以，你知道的，我只是对以下事情更好奇：我的意思是，有趣的是，每种文化都有自己的饮酒文化。而且，这是一种如此专业化、本土化的东西，却不知何故流传了下来。就像你可以去纽约的一些地方，那里的货架上有两三百种阿马罗苦露酒。那些你从未见过、产量极少的东西，甚至像精酿啤酒那样，我认为美国人确实做得很好。
It's just a cool thing to nerd out on. And it's like a fun, pretty inexpensive consumable I think stuff like that is really fun I'm not terribly pretentious about other than Moby Dick I don't think I have any terrible pretensions I'm
这真是一件值得深入研究的酷事。而且它是一种有趣且相当便宜的消费品，我认为诸如此类的东西真的很有趣。对于除了《白鲸记》之外的其他事情，我并没有表现得过于自命不凡，我想我没有什么可怕的虚伪面具。我
expecting that you're like a casual 2400 ranked I don't have time for any of that stuff I wish I just gotta write my compiler all day it's terrible existence really yeah i i i watch a lot of movies i probably see like three movies a week at the theaters yeah that's an interesting john thing sean watches a lot of movies yeah oh wow you can get a pass from amc for like 24 a month and since there's so many theaters in new york so i go
预计你是一个随随便便就能达到 2400 分的高手，或者“我可没时间搞那些乱七八糟的，我只希望整天写我的编译器”，这真是一种可怕的存在，真的。是的，我看了很多电影，我大概一周在电影院看三部电影。是的，这是一件很有趣的肖恩式的趣事，肖恩看很多电影。是的，哦，哇，你可以花大约 24 美元买一张 AMC 的通票，因为纽约有那么多电影院，所以我一周去
to like times square like three times a week and i see whatever they have um and i what's so many theaters in New York so I go to Times Square like three times a week and I see whatever they have and I Do you have like a favorite or top three movie similar to Moby Dick that's you know Oh wow, boy, there's so many great movies 1961 Kobayashi Harakiri
时代广场大概三次，看他们正在上映的任何电影，而且我……纽约有那么多电影院，所以我一周去时代广场大概三次，看他们正在上映的任何电影，并且我……你有没有最喜欢或排名前三的电影，类似于《白鲸记》那种，你知道的……哦，天哪，有太多好电影了。1961 年小林正树的《切腹》
it's like a character in a collection thing about samurais I think that might be my favorite I've actually seen that. That is a great movie. That's a great, great movie. Really severe cinematography. A lot of, like, right angles everywhere. There's courtyard, black and white.
这就像是一部关于武士的合集电影中的角色，我想这可能是我最喜欢的电影。我其实看过那部电影。那是一部极好的电影。那是一部非常、非常棒的电影。摄影风格极其严厉。到处都是直角。有庭院，黑白的。
Incredible. Chic. My mom really likes that movie, but it's a jerk. Yeah. I love Spider-Verse. Like, I saw Spider-Verse a verse a million times because yeah it's just like it's a great movie the lego movie is a great movie another one it's like you're gonna do a toy movie and you're gonna put like these incredible themes in it
难以置信。时髦。我妈妈真的很喜欢那部电影，但它很残酷。是的。我喜欢《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》。就像，我把《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》看了一百万遍，因为，是的，这只是一部伟大的电影。《乐高大电影》也是一部伟大的电影，另一部则是，如果你要拍一部玩具电影，你却把这些不可思议的主题放进去……
business business business that's like yeah is this working lord business is president business um are you excited for spider verse uh number two whatever it's called two and three there's two more coming out oh didn't know i hope they're good um little women i thought was really good um little women i saw that a bunch of times they had uh tim chalamet sersha ronan i did not see that i'm thinking of like i heard that i haven't seen that thinking about little fires which is like a TV show or something. Little Women is, it's like a,
商业、商业、商业，那就是，是的，这管用吗？愿景总统商业，老总商业……你对《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》第二部或者叫什么来着期待吗？第二部和第三部，还有两部要上映呢。哦，我不知道。我希望它们能好看。嗯，《小妇人》，我觉得真的很棒。嗯，《小妇人》，我看过好多次。里面有蒂莫西·柴勒梅德（Timothée Chalamet）、西尔莎·罗南（Saoirse Ronan）。我没看过那个。我在想，就像，我听说过，我没看过那个。我想到了《星星之火》（Little Fires），那是部电视剧什么的。《小妇人》是，它就像是一部，
I could compare it to like Two English Girls, a Truffaut movie. It has like a real French New Wave feeling, even though it doesn't look like a French New Wave movie. But it's excellently, like just so many good decisions when the director made it.
我可以把它和特吕弗（Truffaut）的电影《两个英国女孩》进行比较。它有一种真正的法国新浪潮的感觉，尽管它看起来不像一部法国新浪潮电影。但它非常出色，导演在制作时做出了如此之多的明智决定。
I thought The Green Knight that came out last year was fantastic. I love that. Really that came out last year was fantastic. Really? I got like 10 minutes into that on an airplane ride. That is not the time to see it. It's not an airplane movie.
我觉得去年上映的《绿衣骑士》简直棒极了。我非常喜欢那部电影。去年上映的那部真的是太棒了。真的吗？我在飞机上看了大概 10 分钟就看不下去了。那可不是看这部电影的正确时机。它不是那种适合在飞机上看的电影。
It's a very slow movie. On an airplane, unless you're a pro, you watch a round-the-clock or something. Me, I have much more limited time to watch stuff these days. So now I am watching my quality shows on an airplane. I can't bring myself to watch my top two shows on an airplane. I just don't watch. It's terrible on the back of the seat, whatever.
这是一部节奏非常慢的电影。在飞机上，除非你是老手，否则你会看一些快节奏的爆米花电影之类的东西。而我，这些日子看东西的时间要有限得多。所以现在我在飞机上看我的高质量剧集。我无法说服自己在飞机上观看我最喜欢的两部剧集。我根本不看。椅背上的小屏幕之类的体验太糟糕了。
But yeah, check out Green Knight. I think the montage at the end of the movie. It's like 10 minutes long. It's breathtaking. It's incredible. Did you see the Spencer movie about Lady Di? I thought that was like a masterpiece. Yeah, Kristen Stewart was, you know, it was like so many great ideas in it.
不过，是的，去看看《绿衣骑士》吧。我认为电影结尾处的蒙太奇。大概有 10 分钟长。简直令人窒息。太不可思议了。你看过关于戴安娜王妃的电影《斯宾塞》吗？我觉得那简直是一部杰作。是的，克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特（Kristen Stewart）的表现，你知道的，里面有太多绝妙的创意了。
Anyways, a lot of good movies. Now, I thought the Northman that came out this year was really good. Really? I haven't seen that, but it's not... I don't know. It was awesome. Your taste in movies
不管怎样，有很多好电影。现在，我觉得今年上映的《北方人》真的很棒。真的吗？我没看过那个，但它不是……我不知道。它太棒了。你对电影的品味
is just so varied. What are you talking about? I like good movies. They're all good movies. They're really good. They're tour movies. I'm just saying, like,
真是太杂了。你在说什么？我喜欢好电影。它们都是好电影。它们真的很好。它们是巡回电影。我只是说，
I'm willing to believe that. I'm just saying, like, for me, like, I have a more selective taste in things. What's your favorite movie?
我愿意相信这一点。我只是说，对我来说，我挑选东西的品味更有选择性。你最喜欢的电影是什么？
Connor, what's your favorite movie? I really like Casablanca. I know it's like... I know that's such a trope answer, but I'm like, one, I think it's a great movie, but two, I really... I'm like a World War II history's just anything set in that time period like really sort of works for me um i yeah i really
康纳，你最喜欢的电影是什么？我真的很喜欢《卡萨布兰卡》。我知道这有点……我知道这算是一个老套的回答，但我认为，第一，这是一部伟大的电影；第二，我真的……我是一个二战历史迷，任何以那个时期为背景的东西都非常吸引我。我，是的，我真的很
like casablanca um i saw it uh once in the stanford theater where they use the historical projection techniques. I saw it with my mom. That was a great experience. I'm trying to think about more modern stuff that I really liked. I'll give you a top five. It's hard. I feel like... Connor has a top five.
喜欢《卡萨布兰卡》。我在斯坦福剧院看过一次，他们使用的是历史放映技术。我和我妈妈一起看的。那是一次绝佳的体验。我在想有没有什么更现代的东西是我真正喜欢的。我给你列个前五名吧。这很难。我觉得……康纳有一个前五名榜单。
I'll give you a top five and you can give me your thoughts on each one. For the longest time jurassic park was um one of my favorites and specifically because of the soundtrack um music is like a big thing for me it was a james horner right uh i thought it was john williams yeah um and then i guess i'm interesting yeah this is I'm interested to hear your reaction of this one I for a long
我给你列个前五名，你可以对每一部发表一下看法。在很长一段时间里，《侏儒公园》是……我最喜欢的电影之一，特别是它的配乐。音乐对我来说是一件大事。那是詹姆斯·霍纳（James Horner）的作品吧？我以为那是约翰·威廉姆斯（John Williams）的作品。是的。然后我想我有意思了，是的，这。我很想听听你对这部电影的反应。我有很长
for a while I think La La Land was my number one movie have you seen that I love I love his other movies
一段时间，觉得《爱乐之城》是我的第一名电影。你看过那部电影吗？我喜欢，我喜欢他的其他电影。
but I thought Whiplash and First Man were amazing I didn't like La La Land oh yeah Whiplash was phenomenal I think the I think the director is super talented but like Whiplash and First Man were amazing. I didn't like Lola that much. Oh, yeah. Whiplash was phenomenal.
但我认为《爆裂鼓手》和《登月第一人》太惊艳了。我不太喜欢《爱乐之城》。哦，是的，《爆裂鼓手》简直绝了。我觉得导演才华横溢，但像《爆裂鼓手》和《登月第一人》简直太棒了。我没那么喜欢《爱乐之城》。哦，是的，《爆裂鼓手》简直太惊艳了。
I think the director is super talented, but I just don't like musicals very much. I found my list of things. I respect your choice of director. I think Damien Chazelle is a really talented guy. Wait, let me finish my top five. All right, all right, go for it. Or I'm not even sure this is top five. It's just a list of five movies that I really like.
我觉得这位导演超级有才华，但我只是不太喜欢音乐剧。我找到了我的电影清单。我尊重你对导演的选择。我觉得达米恩·查泽雷（Damien Chazelle）是一个非常具有才华的人。等等，让我列完我的前五名。好吧，好吧，你继续。或者我甚至不确定这算不算前五名。这只是一份我非常喜欢的五部电影的清单。
Potentially, if I had to say one movie, my number one would be Zootopia. Have you seen that? Yeah, the Disney one with the rabbit and the fox. Yeah, and the fox. Okay. Why Zootopia? There's a number of reasons, but I absolutely love the fox character. I cried. I don't think i've told
潜在地，如果我必须说一部电影，我的第一名将是《疯狂动物城》。你看过那部吗？对，就是迪士尼的那部，里面有兔子和狐狸。对，还有那只狐狸。好吧。为什么是《疯狂动物城》？原因有很多，但我绝对喜欢那只狐狸角色。我哭了。我不觉得自己曾在
this story in the podcast i went and saw zootopia twice in one day so i went and saw like a matinee performance um with my ex at the time and uh cried a little bit but like because i i guess i wasn't comfortable crying as hard as I wanted to cry. So then I went back in the evening and saw it again and just like, it was just brutal. Yeah, I'm with you. I mean, that's like me and Spider-Verse, same way. It hits me in that way. Yeah.
播客里讲过这个故事。我一天之内看了两遍《疯狂动物城》。所以我当时和前任一起去看了日场放映，呃，感动得哭了一小会儿，但我猜我当时还不太习惯像自己想哭的那样痛哭流涕。所以我在晚上又回去看了一遍，然后感觉……简直太虐心了。是的，我懂你。我的意思是，这就好比我和《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》一样，感觉完全一样。它就是能触动我内心最深处。是的。
So yeah. And then the last two are probably not number one, but just amazing movies, Fight Club and Good Will Hunting. I like Good Will Hunting. probably not number one but just amazing movies uh fight club and goodwill hunting i like goodwill yeah i i found my list of uh uh movies that i like i'm much more a tv person so i'll give you some tv things after that but um i think i think for top things i would have to say star wars that's probably been which one um the original three episodes. And I say that, like, it's not that... Casablanca is probably, like, the movie that I think is, like, of highest quality. But Star Wars are the movies that have had, like, the biggest impact on my life. Because, like, as a kid, it was just very influential. I played a lot of text-based games, MUDs, as a kid, and that's actually what got me into programming.
所以，是的。然后最后两部可能不是第一名，但绝对是神作：《搏击俱乐部》和《心灵捕手》。我喜欢《心灵捕手》。可能不是第一名，但绝对是神作：呃，《搏击俱乐部》和《心灵捕手》。我喜欢《心灵捕手》。是的。我找到了我喜欢的电影清单。我更是一个电视剧迷，所以我之后会告诉你一些电视剧。不过，我想，对于顶级的作品，我不得不说是《星球大战》，那大概是……哪一部？前三部曲。而且我说这话的意思并不是……《卡萨布兰卡》可能是我认为质量最高的电影。但《星球大战》是对我人生影响最大的电影。因为作为一个孩子，它实在太具影响力了。我小时候玩了很多基于文本的游戏，MUD，而这实际上才是我走上编程之路的契机。
Star Wars MUDs? Yeah, and so I played a lot of Star Wars MUDs. And so the thing that got me into programming was wanting to write my own Star Wars MUD. So I have to say Star Wars, but here's some other things on my list. Dr. Zhivago. Have you seen that? Julie Christie, yeah. Yeah.
《星球大战》MUD？对，我玩了很多《星球大战》MUD。所以让我走上编程之路的原因，就是想要编写我自己的《星球大战》MUD。所以我必须首推《星球大战》，不过我的清单上还有其他一些作品。《日瓦戈医生》。你看过那部吗？朱莉·克里斯蒂（Julie Christie），对。对。
Long movie, but it's one of my mom's favorites too um dragonheart oh my god i really love the dragonheart movies is that the one it's it's got the dragons talk oh god that's terrible with sean with sean connery fights in the dragon it's amazing hi own so there's the first one, which is pretty good. I was just saying I was so unpretentious. And now I'm thinking maybe I'm really pretentious. And then there's like the two others, which are absolute trash. Princess Bride, Indiana Jones, Seven Samurai.
很长的电影，但它也是我妈妈最喜欢的电影之一。哦，天哪，我真的很喜欢《龙之心》系列电影。就是那个有龙会说话的电影吗？哦，天哪，那太糟糕了。肖恩，肖恩·康纳利（Sean Connery）跟那条龙搏斗，这太棒了。我有自己的……所以第一部还挺不错的。我刚才还说我一点也不自命不凡。现在我觉得也许我真的非常自命不凡。然后还有另外两部，绝对是垃圾。还有《公主新娘》、《印第安纳·琼斯》、《七武士》。
Have you seen that? Yeah, I like Seven Samurai. Although, I mean, I think we can do... I mean, okay. High and Blue, I think it's like better than Seven Samurai for those, I mean, I mean, okay. I think it's better than Seven Samurai. You know what I mean? I really like Seven Samurai. Have you seen The Pig?
你看过那部吗？对，我喜欢《七武士》。不过，我的意思是，我觉得我们可以……我的意思是，好吧。阳春白雪，我觉得它比《七武士》更好，对于那些，我的意思是，我的意思是，好吧。我觉得它比《七武士》更好。你知道我的意思吗？我真的很喜欢《七武士》。你看过《猪猡》吗？
Yeah, the Nicolas Cage one. Yeah, what did you think of that? It was a good movie. I mean, it was not in my top ten or anything. I think the idea of a fight club for cooks um is kind of cool but it's good to see nicholas cage um i don't know what do you what do you i thought it was good but it wasn't like it didn't super it didn't blow me away in the way that like
对，尼古拉斯·凯奇演的那部。对，你觉得那部怎么样？那是一部好电影。我的意思是，它并不在我的前十名之内。我觉得为厨师们建立一个搏击俱乐部这个想法挺酷的，但能看到尼古拉斯·凯奇出演感觉很好。我不知道，你觉得呢？我觉得它挺不错的，但它并没有让我惊艳到像……
spencer blew me away or like titan which i think came at the same time blew me away yeah i mean i i loved uh pig and it was all it's like it's like john wick but like different but well he never which I think came at the same time blew me away yeah I mean I loved Pig and it was it's like it's like John Wick but like different but well
《斯宾塞》惊艳到我，或者像《钛》那样几乎同时上映的电影惊艳到我的程度。是的，我的意思是，我很喜欢《猪猡》，而且它有点像……它就像《约翰·威克》，但又有所不同，不过，虽然它几乎同时上映，但它惊艳到我了。是的，我的意思是，我很喜欢《猪猡》，它就像《约翰·威克》，但又有所不同，不过，
he never he never has he never goes into cage rage that's the thing you're expecting him to lose it yeah and he just cooks a meal
他从来没有……他从来没有发过凯奇式的狂怒。这就是关键所在。你期待他会彻底失控，对吧，而他只是做了一顿饭，
and then they cry and that's that's the cage rage at the end I will I will in this episode you're now listening to me or I'll put a little
然后大家一起哭泣，这就是最后的凯奇式狂怒。我会在本期节目中……你现在正在听我说话，我会加一个小
disclaimer if you don't want pig spoiled uh not that that spoiled it but it's a little bit of a spoiler everyone should go watch pig though because it's a that's a it's a it's a very fine movie nick cage he has a pig it's like john wick except replace uh with Nick Cage and replace his dog with a pig. Someone takes a pig and then he goes and fixes it. There's a kind of. A kind of. There's a fair amount of misdirection. Yeah.
免责声明，如果你不想被剧透《猪猡》的话——倒也不是说这算剧透，但这确实有一点点剧透。每个人都应该去看看《猪猡》，因为那是一部非常优秀的电影。尼古拉斯·凯奇，他有一头猪。这就好比《约翰·威克》，只不过把狗换成了尼古拉斯·凯奇，然后把他的狗换成了一头猪。有人带走了这头猪，然后他去把事情解决了。这里面有相当多的……相当多的……有相当多的误导。是的。
I mean, if you watch the trailer, it just shows a truffle pig. You definitely expect more. Someone took my pig. And then he goes and uh yeah anyway there won't say anything more but it's um i was i was not expecting much when i watched it and uh and then was man you gotta you gotta see that 824 neon stuff just like whenever they come out with an 824 neon movie go see it because that's that's what they do you know 824 neon i don't even know what that this is the the two like they buy movies
我的意思是，如果你看了预告片，它只展示了一头松露猪。你绝对会期待更多。有人拿走了我的猪。然后他去……是的，不管怎样，我不会再多剧透了，但它……我当时看的时候并没有抱太大期望，结果……天哪，你一定要去看看 A24、霓虹（Neon）发行的那些电影。只要 A24 或霓虹推出一部电影，就去看吧，因为那就是他们的风格，你知道的。A24、霓虹，我甚至不知道这到底是什么……这是两家公司，他们会在电影节之后购买电影并进行宣传，所以他们是发行商，而且他们品味极佳，你知道的，或者至少他们制作、购买有趣的电影。所以他们买下了《猪猡》，还有《钛》、《绿衣骑士》、《斯宾塞》，几乎所有好电影。有趣的是，你绝对必须是个影迷。去看看霓虹发行的电影吧。我要宣读我电影清单的剩余部分，然后我们看看我们还能不能做朋友。好吧。
after festivals and they promote them so they're like the distributor and they have just have good taste you know or at least like they make they buy interesting movies so they bought they've got pig and they got titan and green knight spencer pretty much everything that's good interesting it's definitely like you know you're you've got to be a movie buff. Go see the neon stuff. I'm going to read the rest of my movie list, and we're going to see whether we're still friends. All right.
《律政俏佳人》。什么？那不是瑞茜演的吗？她叫什么名字？对，对。瑞茜？《千钧一发》？你看过《千钧一发》。我没看过《千钧一发》。
Legally Blonde. What? Isn't that the one with, like, Reeve? What's her name? Yep, yep. Reeves? Gattaca? You've seen Gattaca. I haven't seen Gattaca.
我真的很喜欢《千钧一发》。这是我喜欢的那种反乌托邦题材。《记忆碎片》？《记忆碎片》不错。是的。让我们看看，我们这里还有什么？我把《侏儒公园》列进去了。我通常不喜欢恐怖类型的片子……《五角大楼之战》，那只是一部
I really like Gattaca. It's like the sort of dystopian that I like. Memento? Memento's good. Yeah. And let's see, what else do we have on here? I did have Jurassic Park on here. And I usually don't like horror horror type stuff um the pentagon wars it's just a
非常有趣的电影，我喜欢《五角大楼之战》。你从来没看过这部电影……让我们看看这里还有什么……《海角乐园》……还有《逃亡与征服》（To Have and Have Not），这非常类似于《卡萨布兰卡》。你看过那部吗？不，我想没有。那是那种诺尔（Noir）风格的东西吗？对，是同一个亨弗莱·鲍嘉（Humphrey Bogart），我忘了那个女演员的名字了，我想是同样的两个主演。
really funny movie i like the pentagon wars you've never seen this movie um let's see what else do we have on here uh to haven and uh to have and have not which is very similar to Casablanca. Have you seen that? No, I don't think so. It's a Nora kind of thing? Yeah, it's the same Humphrey Bogart, I forget the woman's name, the same two leads I think.
哦，真的吗？好的。是的，而且背景有点类似。《迷失东京》，那真的是一部很棒的电影，里面有那个地方的……比尔·默瑞（Bill Murray），对，还有斯嘉丽·约翰逊（Scarlett Johansson），是的，还有《蒂凡尼的早餐》，是的。你确实更偏爱……是的，我得同意莉娜的看法。至于电视剧，可能只是因为我最近重温过，我最喜欢的电视剧之一大概是《星际之门》……我至少把整个《星际之门》电视剧传奇完整看了一遍五遍，这绝对是一个巨大的承诺，因为内容太多了。你可以写一个 C++ 编译器……我从来没有……我从来没能看完。我曾试图看《星际之旅》，但我从没看完过。我在《星际迷航：深空九号》（DS9）中途卡住了，实在无法再看下去了。而且……我最喜欢的当前播出的电视剧是《西部世界》。在你进来之前我刚刚在看，因为女朋友现在不在，所以我可以在大电视上赶我那些狗屎一样的电视剧了，而且音量还可以调到我喜欢的水平。对。
Oh really? Okay. Yeah, and it's sort of a similar setting. Lost in Translation, that's a really good one with the what's this place Bill Murray yeah and scarlet Johansson yeah yeah and breakfast at Tiffany's yeah you are you are more of a place yeah I would have to concur with Lee now for TV and it's probably just because i've done my most recent re-watching probably one of my favorite tv shows stargate um i i have i have
是的。好了，我们得结束今天的节目了。是的，我们必须得结束了。不过，我们会说这是一次非常棒的节目。
watched the entire stargate like um tv saga at least five times and that is like a big commitment because there's a lot there you could write a c++ compiler i've never i've never gotten through i've tried to do it with star trek i've never gotten through the i got stuck in like midway through ds9 and i just couldn't i couldn't go any further um and uh what my my favorite like current tv is westworld um i was i was just watching that before you came in uh because the girlfriend's gone now so i can catch up on my fucking shows on the big tv with the volume set to a level that i like yep um yeah all right we gotta wrap things up yeah We got to. We are. But, well, we'll say this has been a fantastic show.
我得说，我可能会对这期节目做点特别的处理。通常我们会把它切成 30 分钟左右的片段。但也许吧，我不知道。我们还得拭目以待，因为这会给我增加更多的工作量。我大概只会把它切成两半。我觉得给第一集或者这一半起个标题，比如《C++ 对比 Carbon 对比 Circle 对比 CPP Front 或 CPP 2.0》，随你怎么叫它。是的，我认为对于那些对 Circle 感兴趣的人来说，会有很多内容，就像你目前正在添加等同于 C++ OX 概念的东西，
I got to say, I might do something special with this in that usually we dice these up into, like, 30-minute segments. But maybe, I don't know. We'll have to see because it will take more work for me. I'll only cut this in half. I think like titling the first episode C++ or like the first half of this C++ versus Carbon versus Circle versus CPP Front or CPP 2.0, whatever you want to call it. Yeah, I think there's going to be a lot, for folks that are interested in Circle, like you're currently adding the equivalent of C++ OX concepts
可能会对此感兴趣，或者现在就去了解一下。我每天都在推特上发相关内容。所以我关注了你的推特。肖恩·巴克斯（Sean Bax）。那是 Circle-Lang？对，Circle--lang.org，但我其实并不怎么
and that might be interested in checking that out or even checking it out right now. I tweet about it every day. So I follow you on Twitter. Sean Bax. And it's Circle-Lang? Yeah, Circle--lang.org but I don't really
更新网站，我只是……我只是目前在努力写代码，你知道的。是的，就是埋头苦干。
update the website I just I just try to yeah we gotta get you I just try to work right now you know yeah just working
仅此而已。好的，谢谢，谢谢大家陪我们度过了两个半小时，我已经迫不及待地想看看网上的朋友们对这期节目的反馈了，因为这一定会很精彩。
that's all yeah alright well thanks thanks for hanging out for two and a half hours and I can't wait to see the feedback
是的，嘿，康纳，我想让那期洗手间内容的播客播出。感谢大家的收听，我们希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天！
we get from folks on the internets from this because it's gonna be exciting yeah and hey i want that bathroom episode to air connor thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。